有的孩子能看到妈妈的辛苦，
看到妈妈的牺牲，
心疼妈妈，
就想长大了买房子，
让妈妈过好日子，
有的孩子他只会看到他的生活比不过别人，
他向往的就是别人开豪车，
别人住大房子，
别人能有游泳池，
别人能够买得起什么1000块钱的鞋子，
买得起什么1000块钱的书包，
孩子跟孩子不一样，
你尽早的去客观的分析你的孩子，
如果你的孩子他骨子里他就是想要他爸那样的好生活，
好条件的话，
你现在放手，
损失最小。
26岁的时候，
父亲去世了，
母亲在嫁了，
母亲她是一个那个伏地魔，
比较重男轻女，
29岁的时候生完孩子，
然后我就是中间没有工作，
然后那个十年的家庭主妇，
在我那个生完孩子，
一岁的时候，
前夫出车分手了，
当时我是要非常全，
我前夫他是条件比较好的，
我就没有要一分财产。
现在面临的问题是这样，
他去那个某院去起诉我，
想跟我争夺那个抚养权，
说我欠了他15个，
问题是这15个我不知道他怎么来给我定义的空间是他把孩子弄到成都那边去读书，
我每周去接送，
然后的那个私密学所能够自己知道的是有他给了我就是将近8个W。
我等房租另外的钱，
一个月给我2K的车费，
但这个问题他是经过我妈妈来中间来传话同钱问菲菲姐的是我可能失去抚养权吗？
多大的孩子，
孩子是现在有10岁，
那孩子愿意跟你吗？
孩子喜欢他爸爸吗？
因为现在想要变更孩子的抚养权，
最主要的孩子的意愿，
孩子如果说特别喜欢他爸爸，
想要跟他爸爸一起生活的话，
确实存在这样的风险，
孩子如果喜欢你，
想跟你一起生活的话，
他爸爸条件再好也没有用，
我是重庆这边的，
我现在就是快40岁嘛，
在成都那边了，
这学期开学的时候，
我把孩子弄回我们，
就是重庆这边，
孩子就一直跟着我，
但是我就发现孩子的三观有一些改变，
我条件没有那么好，
我那个情他是在这个月的3月12号来学校强行的把孩子接走，
孩子到现在没有给我打过一个电话，
所以我可能继续看流全是吗？
鸵鸟啊，
我这话讲起来就扎心了啊，
如果这个孩子他确实向往条件比较好，
环境比较好，
生活比较好的地方，
我们也只能尊重他，
否则的话，
他现在10岁，
你失去他的抚养权，
等你把他养到20岁，
他跟你照样不亲，
哪个对于你来说损失更大，
我跟你说，
孩子这个东西啊，
出场设置非常重要，
因为孩子跟孩子他就是不一。
一样，
有的孩子能看到妈妈的辛苦，
看到妈妈的牺牲，
心疼妈妈，
就想长大了买房子，
让妈妈过好日子。
有的孩子他只会看到他的生活比不过别人，
他向往的就是别人开豪车，
别人住大房子，
别人能有游泳池，
别人能够请什么，
买得起什么1000块钱的鞋子，
买得起什么1000块钱的书包。
孩子跟孩子不一样，
你尽早的去客观的分析你的孩子，
如果你的孩子他骨子里他就是想要他爸那样的好生活好条件的话，
你现在放手，
损失最小，
你等他20岁了之后，
你没有能力给他买房吧，
你没有能力给他找工作吧，
你没有能力给他出彩礼吧，
他那个时候他再恨你，
他在嫌弃你的话，
你是个损失更大。
我明白了，
我也觉得我现在的情况有点像最近说过的那个电视剧里面的那个奶尿那里面另外一个角色。
第二个问题，
菲姐，
我再想问一下，
就如果失去了抚养权的话，
当初我没有要一分财产，
现在我们还能要求重新分割财产吗？
很难啊，
除非说现在有证据证明当时他对你进行了隐瞒，
欺骗他的财产，
比如说他背着你在三亚买了一套房，
背着你在国外买了一套房，
如果说有这种隐瞒欺骗的存在的话，
是有可能重新分割的，
但如果没有这样的隐瞒和欺骗，
你当时自愿。
放弃了财产，
当然你可能是因为想要孩子的抚养权，
所以自愿放弃了，
但不管你自愿是什么原因，
你自愿放弃了，
放弃了就是放弃了，
现在再想要重新分割是很难，
谢谢，
然后第三个问题是我没有，
就是很高的文凭，
就业大的那种专科吧，
就是请教您一下，
我接下来的路该怎么走呢？
你差不多40岁，
接下来的路好好的为自己的养老做打算，
没有人靠得住父母，
父亲走了啊，
妈妈靠不住，
男人你也经历过了，
孩子你也经历过了，
谁都靠不住。
接下来的日子就是靠自己，
给自己养好，
给自己一日三餐吃饱穿暖，
给自己预备养老钱，
哪个挣钱就干哪个，
干哪个都不丢人。
我要是你40岁的年纪正当年，
我要是没有什么文化的话，
我就去学个月儿嫂，
我就去学个月嫂，
我就去学营养师，
我就去学怎么带孩子，
我现在就是手里20个，
我现在想问你一下，
我现在需要去买房吗？
我需要是需要你20个，
你留在手里是你的活命钱，
比如说因为带孩子很辛苦啊，
责任心，
每天那个精神都绷的很紧，
你要是不喜欢这些工作的话，
我这20万我还可以学点手艺，
哪怕我学个什么椒麻鸡，
学个卤肥肠，
学个什么卤鸡爪，
我都得要投入，
哪怕我自己也做个小摊儿，
我是不是也得投入本金，
但不要买房子，
一旦买了房子，
这个钱就变成死钱，
你就。
这种压力，
那现在就是先租房子住嘛，
对，
没错，
选个手艺，
其他的没有任何问题了，
这就这样啊，
要给自己去了解，
交养老交社保，
哪怕自己是一个灵活就业的，
也是自己可以交社保交养老的，
交社保起到什么好处呢？
比如说医疗保险，
万一将来真真有个什么三病两痛的还能报销，
做育儿嫂呢，
这个工作呢，
他确实挺攒钱的，
为什么？
因为育儿嫂他没有消费，
钱花不出去，
衣食住行都是主家全包嘛，
对不对？
基本上吧，
衣服你穿不了几件，
她天天带孩子，
你又没时间去展示，
没有时间就穿漂亮的裙子，
高跟鞋，
天天带孩子，
是不是都是T恤裤子运动鞋，
T恤裤子脱鞋，
所以他衣食住行基本上主假全包了，
但是呢，
月儿嫂这个工作他是高度紧张的，
因实你时刻都担心孩子，
他割了碰了撞了，
吃了什么不该吃的东西了啊，
时刻担心这个月儿嫂吃一个辛苦活，
但他能攒钱就是看你第一有没有这个责任心，
第二能不能吃得了这个苦。
带小孩子真的不容易的，
他是一天的精神都是紧绷的，
哪怕小孩子在那喝奶，
他都得看着，
怕小孩呛奶啊什么的啊。
带小孩子不容易的，
记得点赞关注哦。